esta lluvia es una de esas condiciones
climáticas que marca Las mayores
dificultades ahora que llega el invierno
estamos en la ciudad de nipro a 4 horas
del frente del donbas de donde
regresamos anoche y allí nos contaban
quienes pelean en ese frente que en este
momento cuando regresa el agua y se
descongela la nieve que ha caído en los
últimos días hace imposible la vida en
esas trincheras que cada vez son más
activas especialmente en la ciudad de
backmud donde la pelea se intensifica
cada día más pero también nos cuenta que
trae sus ventajas porque esta Niebla
hace casi imposible el vuelo de los
drones que son fundamentales en esta
guerra que comenzó el 24 de febrero
solamente anoche los rusos volvían a
lanzar 14 drones de fabricación
iranídrones casi que fueron
interceptados por la defensas ucranianas
pero allí en el frente nos cuentan que
hay dos tipos de drones que hacen la
vida imposible tanto para unos como para
otros el primero es el dron
una un dron Ruso que vuela bastante alto
y que tiene una cámara con bastante
precisión que ayuda a dar mensajes y a
precisar la artillería lo que hace que
los rusos estén atacando con mayor
precisión en especialmente en la
posición de los ucranianos también usan
sus drones especialmente drones
comerciales los típicos que se consiguen
en cualquier tienda que ellos utilizan
para también controlar las posiciones
enemigas y estos soldados especialmente
por los voluntarios ucranianos estamos
en una estación de gasolina por ejemplo
donde cada litro que se consume da una
un grigna o la moneda de ucraniana para
comprar esos drones que ayudan a los
soldados en el frente de batalla